what's going on everyone if you've ever
struggled to figure out all the
different numbers
in marketing and figure out what's
important what's not important what's
good what's bad
um and you just can't get your stuff to
convert or you can't make you can't make
sense of all this stuff
then this video is for you all right so
when i got into marketing
there were so many different numbers
kpis cpl cpc
like ctrs i like i was like i was i had
no idea my head was spinning i was
trying to figure it out
um and over time it's kind of like you
start to distill down what are the big
buckets of
things that matter and then once you
discover what those three are
then you can open up the drawer and look
for more details and whatnot and so what
i want to do is outline the three
numbers that i'm looking at at a high
level in any business that i'm looking
to invest in or i'm looking to
partner with or whatever all right and
i'll show you the relationship between
them
that i am looking for and hopefully that
will help you
uh for your own business so the first
number is
what my cost of acquisition is which i
call cac all right that's not i call it
that's what people call it right
cost of acquisition or cac right so how
much does it cost me to acquire a
customer
now this number should include
everything so that means your sales
commission that means your ad spend it
means the marketing team that created
the inquiries whatever
your software that's associated with it
it's all of the costs
of acquisition put together that is cac
all right
number two is ltv
now i define this a little bit
differently
um because i think it's important so ltv
is not the total revenue that i'm going
to get over the
lifespan of a customer but for me it's
the total gross profit
that i'm going to get over the lifespan
of a customer so let me give you a
simple example
so if i were selling meals for example
or selling food
and my cost of uh of of delivering food
let's say was uh
nine bucks all right and i know that
someone's gonna order seven hundred
dollars
a month of food and it cost me nine
dollars and i'm selling it for ten
all right that means i only have a ten
percent margin on gross profit
right gross profit uh on the meal sold
and so 700
um of food over the lifespan of a
customer might sound like a huge ltv
but the reality is it's actually only
70 which is what i'm going to make on
that customer right
and so the reason i use gross profit is
that if i were doing marketing for food
for example
and uh you know my marketing team was
like hey man we're spending 200
to acquire a customer who's going to pay
us 700. i would be like that's horrible
because we only make 70
on the 700 which means that we're
spending 200 to make 70. right and
that's why it's so important
to understand the gross margin of your
business
right because this is where all of your
decisions should be based off of all
right it's on that margin
the third number is what i call 30 day
cash
all right now in the formal business
world the fancy world
they call this they they use a different
uh metric they call it payback period
which is
how long does it take you to pay back
your cost of acquisition right because
inherently whenever you're getting a
customer there's usually a cost that's
put into it
and that cost might there's always a
cost you're either paying in time or
you're paying in money
or you're paying in someone else's time
which is then payroll hours but there's
always a cost
right there's a cost of acquiring
customer and then you have
uh the payback period i use 30 day cash
for this reason i think that virtually
every business
can gain access to a credit line which
means a credit card or an amex or even a
bank and gallon you whatever
um where over 30 days they can they can
use that money and then pay it back
virtually interest-free credit cards are
all interest-free
for the first 30 days all right or at
least all the ones that i'm aware of
right
and so what that means is that if i can
if i can know what my 30-day cash value
is
and if i can get that to be at least
equal to my cac
then it means that i can use other
people's money
to acquire customers and this is why
we've had such big growth in the
companies that i've had is that i don't
actually need to use my own money to
acquire customers
i can use someone else's money acquire
them get the money in the first 30 days
to
pay back the debt and now i'm left over
with customers and ideally customers and
profit that i can still continually
upsell
into continuity if you can understand
the words that i'm saying right now
you'll understand how big of a deal
this is all right so what are the
relationships that i'm looking for
so for me for ltv like if i'm looking at
it because there's there's different
relationships that i need to draw here
and when i'm looking about how the
marketing is working all right so my
ltv to cac ratio
i want to always have greater greater
than three to one all right three to one
is the number that i'm looking for
which means that i need to be able to
generate more than
three times the cost of acquisition
in gross profit all right so that means
that let's say my gross profit i'll get
a number another number let's say that
my gross profit
on a service that i sell uh is is eighty
percent
all right we'll use that as a number and
so it's 80
is my gross profit and i have a thousand
dollar
lifetime all right that's how much
they're going to spend with me over the
lifetime
which means eight hundred dollars is
what
i am going to use as my number now if
eight hundred dollars is what i make
then i have to three to one be able to
acquire customers
for less than 270 or whatever two
hundred 265.66 dollars right
um so my cost of acquisition has to be
less than
266 dollars all right that's the total
thing
now that's the first uh relationship
that i'm gonna look at the next
relationship that i'm gonna look at
is the 30-day cash uh requirement
compared to my cac
and so for me if i have a one-to-one
relationship between
my 30-day cash
and my cac then that means that i am
breaking even
on getting customers all right and i'm
breaking even within a window
that i can use other people's money to
finance the acquisition and that's where
this gets super cool
all right and so using the example that
we just had
if 260 dollars is what it it has to be
under right for me to get three to one
then
let's say that if i can just get my ah
if i can get my 30-day cash
to be greater than 260
then it means that in the first 30 days
i'm breaking even in my acquisition for
free
and then i'm still going to collect the
other
500 in whatever dollars that's remaining
from this process
and so those are the two biggest
relationships that i'm looking at
what's my ltv to cac ratio and what's my
30-day cash
to cac ratio all right i want this
to be greater than three times what it
cost me to acquire a customer
and that is how i know i'll have
sufficient profit to grow the business
i want my 30-day cash in my cac to be at
least
greater than one so that i know that i
can use other people's money
opm to acquire customers
all right this is what it looks like
visually
[Applause]
a person comes in the business let's say
i pay
let's say i pay 200 dollars in cac
all right so i'm now negative 200
this person now comes into my business
to do you know they've got their
their little money they come into my
business
they decide to give me money right
now at this point this could be you know
day one
and this could be day seven
whatever because it depends how long it
takes them to give me money right and so
maybe the first time they give me money
they only give me 50 bucks
right i'm still negative but by day
30 let's say i have another upsell or
two
and at this point now i've made two
hundred dollars
on this customer
what this means is that now
i've covered my cost of acquisition and
then at the end of this point
i'm going to continue to sell them or
they'll continue to buy let's say it's
on recurring
day 60 day 90 day 120 etc
and i was able to break even to then get
all of this money that happens on the
back end for free
that is the power of this concept and so
to summarize this
the three numbers that you need to
always know when you're marketing
is going to be your cac it's going to
your ltv
important point is that it's the gross
profit not the total revenue
and the 30-day cash that you can make
per customer
and you need to break even on 30-day
cash to cac and you want this to be at
least three times
greater than your cost of acquisition
for you to have a viable business
and that is the game um that i try to
play so anyways i hope that was valuable
for you i hope when you're looking at
your business model you're looking at
your marketing
and you have these metrics you can make
decisions empirically quantitatively
and the nice thing is if something's
below these metrics then you just know
that you have to fix it
is there an upsell or is there is there
some sort of liquidation thing can we
give them some sort of special offer
in their first week or two can we sell
them ancillary products and we have an
affiliate relation can we refer stuff
out in order to increase this 30-day
cash number
the reason this is important is if i can
make this really really big
then it means i can spend more to
acquire on customers which means i can
even
open up further my acquisition net and
still make more money and obviously
the amount that you add your 30 to cash
is still going to add into your total
lifetime value of the customer so hope
that was over for you hope this makes
sense for your business
um this is how i think through these
things and i hope uh
hope you do too have an amazing day
enjoy and
i'll see you next video